Katarina kreis We're here today to reveal all of your evil deeds
My
Hershey, what
's your name Throwing shrimp toys?  Wet
n
You are the daughter of a Marquess
family and
Jr Do-sama's conqueror.  I
've seen it in other
games, and I've seen it in other games.
Catalina, who was made the role of a king of sin, is going to
ruin I wonder if it will
start suddenly
No, but it should have been the capture targets who condemned Catalina
If it was the georde route, or if it was the case route, the case should stand in the way of protecting Maria
But I'm just marketing.  I witnessed it
[music]
This is nothing in the world
Business branch, please look at this
[music]
Me is the narrative of the game
dan